[Music]
[Music]
so about two years ago I was featured in
a New York Times article called
adventures of a teenage polyglot which
featured my passion for learning foreign
languages this peculiar hobby that I had
and at first I thought it was great I
loved the fact that language learning
was getting more attention I love the
fact that would it always seemed like an
isolating hobby was suddenly putting me
into contact with people all around the
world it does I spent more time in the
media spotlight the focus of my story
began to shift so whereas I'd always
been interested in talking about the why
in the how why I was learning foreign
languages how I did it instead it turned
into a bit of a circus in which media
shows wanted to sensationalize my story
so it would go a little something like
this
hello I'm here today with 17 year-old
Timothy donor who is fluent in 20
languages oh I'm sorry
he actually can insult you in 25
languages and is fluent in another 10
Tim how much you tell our audience good
morning and thank you for watching in
Muslim arabic ìand maha duma Auckland
New Zealand Elmo shahida great Tim now
can we get you to introduce yourself and
say I'm fluent in 23 languages in German
it's not really true but no no just tell
the audience hello it's been Tim doner
been Sanada I don't come your fare five
in Spanish pass please inspection
perfect now how about a tongue twister
in Chinese we could talk about Chinese
you know a lot more Americans or
learning Chinese these days and I think
there's a lot of value and that no no no
just give us a tongue twister to pool
pool pool table here Porter pool pool
pool table here this guy Tim have
another tongue twister in Chinese I
would prefer not to but you know we
could talk about China you know there's
a lot that you can gain by learning a
language Oh Tim I'm sorry that's all the
time we have
now why don't you tell our audience
goodbye in Turkish and we'll be over
here you know we haven't talked about
anything substantive but Turkish please
Heidi buckling the mom you'll agree
never choke to death of him how about
that kid right
I wonder if he gets any girls now stay
with us because up next a skateboarding
bulldog in a bathing suit
[Laughter]
so as funny as that was it highlighted
two pretty major problems in the way my
story was covered on a personal level I
felt that language learning was now
becoming like a bit of a task almost and
felt it felt like something that was
suddenly had to be originally a rigidly
organized something that had to be
compartmentalized rationalized expressed
in a concrete number I speak X languages
I know Y languages as opposed to what
I'd always done which was just learning
languages for the fun of it learning to
communicate with people learning about
foreign cultures and on a bigger level
it cheapened what it meant to speak a
language or to know a language now if I
can impart you with anything today at
TEDx team it's that knowing a language
is a lot more than knowing a couple
words out of a dictionary it's a lot
more than being able to ask someone
where the bathroom is or telling them
the time of day but I'm getting ahead of
myself so for those of you who aren't
familiar with my story maybe a lot of
you here don't know what the word
polyglot is and it's pretty weird one I
started here so this little tot is me
circa 2001 and this is the beginning of
my language learning journey I actually
was a child actor before I learned any
languages and I always had a little bit
of a gift for accents so I would go into
auditions for radio commercials or for
TV commercials and I would do an Austin
Powers impression I'm not gonna do one
now
or maybe I would do a poo from the
Simpsons in fact there was actually one
time in addition to which I was asked to
leave because they told me to speak like
a little kid with a lisp and I wanted to
do Darth Vader in a French accent
but that taught me the basics of how to
break down sound how to pick up a
foreign accent or foreign speech
patterns and really live with it now
fast-forward a little bit I'm now in
about third grade and I've just started
French for the first time but six months
into it a year into it even two years
later I can't converse with anybody
French is just another subject in school
and even though I can tell you words for
elbow knee bone shoelace I couldn't
really have a fluent conversation with
anybody fast-forward a little bit more
in seventh grade I started Latin so
Latin of course is a dead language and
in learning Latin you really learn how
to break down language to see language
as a system with rules and as a bit of a
puzzle so that was great but I still
didn't feel like language was for me so
for it a little bit more about thirteen
and out of an interest in learning more
about the israeli-palestinian conflict I
started studying Hebrew now I had no way
of doing it I had no idea what I was
supposed to be doing so I listened to a
lot of rap music
I've memorized lyrics I'd spit them back
out and I would just tried to chat with
native speakers once a week once a month
and I found that incrementally I started
to understand a lot more now I didn't
sound like a native speaker I couldn't
speak very articulately and I certainly
didn't know the grammar but I had done
what I had never managed to do in school
which was to pick up the basics of a
language all on my own for it a little
bit more I started taking Arabic when I
was 14 in a summer program going into
ninth grade this was summer of 2010
after a month I found that I could read
and write we've had a problem I learned
the basics of the formal language and
one of its major dialects and it turned
me on to the fact that I really could
pursue languages as a hobby so it
finally came to March 24th 2011 so I'm
pretty vicious insomnia and as I was
studying more languages using grammar
books or watching TV shows and let's say
maker Hebrew became one way of focusing
my time so on that night while I was
awake till some ungodly hour I recorded
myself speaking Arabic into my computer
screen
subtitled it and I uploaded it to
YouTube under the title Tim speaks
Arabic Timothy element of Al Arabiya
next day I did the same thing team at
the veil wait
Tim speaks Hebrew and the comments when
they trickled in were fantastic I got
things like wow I've never seen an
American speak Arabic before you blame
them in addition to that I got things
like wow maybe you should you should fix
your vowels here or maybe this word is
pronounced this way so suddenly language
learning had gone from the solitary
pages of a book or my computer screen
into the wide world after that I was
hooked
I had a community of speakers to
interact with and I essentially had a
teacher or conversational partners for
any language that I wanted to do so show
you a quick montage of that to get a set
they loved her and I am under how LA
Manzana anymore lassitude but Kira Kira
um but Holly Malo in Maui she say yo to
Cali the Covelli stove the I love it you
get you get me Masonic and done Oh Joey
like in a juicy little routine ambani an
electronic key difference key ferrocene
as Mottola for stange dara dara monana
roster per share the hood a poem on
that became my way of reaching out to
the world but as I was learning all
these languages I faced a number of
obstacles so number one I had no idea
how to teach myself in fact I'm sure
many of you if you were told you have to
learn Pashto by next month you wouldn't
know what to do so I experimented here's
one thing so in my Latin class I read
about something that Cicero described
called method of loci or technically low
quorum but it's a technique in which you
take mnemonics so let's say you want to
learn ten vocab words on a list you take
each of those words and instead of
memorizing them in blocks you integrate
them into your spatial memory so here's
what I mean this spot right here is
Union Square it's a place I go every day
if I close my eyes I can imagine it very
very vividly so I imagine myself walking
down Union Square and in each spot in my
mind that has resonance I associate it
with a vocab word I'll show you right
now I'm walking down Park Avenue and the
Japanese to walk is EQ I go a little bit
further TURN RIGHT sit on the steps
where I can Sawada directly north of
there is a statue of George Washington
which I used to think was a fountain so
that's no mood to drink right next item
is a tree that you can key to cut if you
want to go north to a Barnes & Noble you
can yomu to read or if I'm hungry I want
to go to my favorite falafel place I can
go one block west of there so I can pop
I do to eat I miss one all right so
eight out of ten not bad so I found that
most of the time by experimenting with
methods like these it made language
learning a much more interactive
experience it made it something that I
could remember much better and I had a
lot of fun with maybe that's not for you
here's another one so a lot of people
often ask me if you're studying so many
languages at the same time how do you
not confuse them or how do you learn so
many vocab words in Spanish I learn the
word for table and then the word for
book goes out the other ear what I do is
embrace those so for example take these
three words in Indonesian these were
actually among the first 50 words that I
learned Kabbalah Caban contour lexically
they're unrelated to each other
Kabbalah is a head combat is news
contour is an office but they all sound
similar ka right so what I would do is I
would memorize vocab in batches of
sounds that were similar so if I hear
the word capella Indonesian I
automatically think the words come out
in contour same in Arabic if this all
is they'll support those three words are
unrelated when his economy one is
independence one is downfall but if I
hear one it triggers it triggers the
rest same thing in Hebrew closes oh hey
Zola even though those are returned
remember into shine or in Farsi in which
they are related so for me if I hear the
word Pitts ad which means father I
automatically think of the words ma dad
battled AB the host ad mother brother
daughter so again this is one method and
I'm not saying this will make you fluent
in a language but it has been one of my
ways of overcoming those obstacles so
you may be wondering what's the point in
doing this why learned Pashto or Ojibwe
when you live in New York and there's a
point to that
in fact I've lived in New York my entire
life and I'm always blown away by the
number of languages you can hear on a
given day walking down the street I see
billboards and Chinese or in Spanish I
see Russian bookstores Indian
restaurants Turkish bath houses yet for
all that linguistic diversity mainstream
American culture remains decidedly
monolingual and if you don't think
that's true look at the reactions to
coca-cola Superbowl video so as I
started to play around Morris language
learning I found that I had my own
community of learners here in New York I
would go out to outer boroughs and for
lack of a better word embarrass myself I
try to talk to people all day get their
views on things and use my newfound
language skills yeah team watching
Prayuth one is Catawba Valley we have a
look at you get up for the dilash
childhood University uh-huh hey miss
miss can I write another hood never saw
was what was written about his own life
okay yes so maybe you have to use a lot
of English maybe you're not really that
articulate or interesting when you talk
but the point is you're getting out
there and you're getting exposure so I
don't speak Urdu that well is kind of
awkward conversation but just from that
I've learned a new word called newish
I'm not gonna forget it now so moving on
you may wonder again what's the
of doing this and I try to explain to
people a lot what my various motivations
are but I often feel that this quote
from Nelson Mandela is the best
expression of that if you talk to a man
in a language he understands that goes
to his head if you talk to him in his
language that goes to his heart so as I
begun to see there's an enormous
connection between language and culture
language and thought and quite honestly
if you want to learn Persian for example
you pick up a dictionary you say I know
how to say thank you I know how to say
how much is this and I know I say
goodbye oh I speak Persian probably not
let's see actually in fact if you want
to buy something in a Persian bookstore
you might ask someone how much is this
generally he'll tell you this probably
now though day which means so in fact
this is an ingrained cultural practice
called taught off in which two people
having a conversation both try to behave
more humble than the other so if I go to
buy a book it's rude for that person to
tell me it's 5 bucks he has to say it's
worthless please you were so good
looking you're so talented you're
whatever take it for free I'm so humble
take it for free or you might find
something like this phrase if you want
to thank somebody if you want to show
your gratitude towards them or say nice
to meet you I could say well I know to
say thank you in Farsi I speak Farsi
maybe not though in fact I've often
heard this phrase when I talk with
Iranians water bonad venom which
literally means so again it's poetic you
might call it melodramatic but this is
something you really have to understand
the culture to get and right and again I
don't want to exotic eyes this because
think about it we have this in English
all the time if you ask somebody how are
you what expecting to hear I'm fine if
you tell me anything else I'm not
interested but we do it anyway we say we
say bless you even though that has no
real religious connotation now when
people sneeze right so it's interesting
you think about the fact that most
linguists believe language doesn't
inherently affect the way you think
right there's no language that will make
you a math genius there's no language
that'll make logic problems impossible
to understand but there's a real tie
between language
culture there's so much language can
tell you about one cultures mindset and
in fact on planet earth every two weeks
another language dies no more people are
speaking it because of war because of
famine oftentimes just because of
assimilation maybe it's easier for me
not to speak my village language but to
speak Arabic let's say or maybe I'm from
a tribe in the Amazon my habitat is cut
down and it just makes more sense for me
to learn Portuguese and lose my culture
so think about that two months from
today is April 1st for any of you that
day may be stressful because you have a
paper due where the rent is due but for
two groups of people around the world
for two cultures that means the death of
their language the death of their
mythology their history their folklore
their understanding of the world
now again you brushing up on your
Spanish going to Japanese class is not
going to stop language death but what it
does do is begin to open up your mind to
the idea that language in its sense in
essence represents a cultural worldview
and if I can impart you with anything
today at TEDx teen it's this you can
translate words easily but you can't
quite translate meaning thank you
[Applause]